welcome everyone and thank you for
joining us for today's seminar a gene
expression based screening platform for
mouse models of late onset Alzheimer's
disease presented by dr. Greg Carter an
associate professor at the Jackson
laboratory
my name is Susie Valdez and I'll be your
moderator for today's event we're
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab roots and
sponsored by nano stream for more
information about our sponsor visit them
at wwo Strang calm before we begin I
want to remind everyone that this event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want during the
presentation simply click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and type those questions
into the drop down box our speaker will
respond to your questions via email
following the presentation if you have
any trouble seeing or hearing this
presentation simply click on the ask a
question box and let us know that you're
experiencing a problem this presentation
is educational and thus offers
continuing education credits click on
the continuing education credit tab it's
located on the top right corner of your
presentation window
and follow the process to obtain those
credits without further ado please join
me in welcoming our presenter today dr.
Greg Carter I will now turn the
presentation over to him welcome dr.
Carter
thank you I'm very much looking courted
talking about our work in late onset
Alzheimer's disease and how we're using
a new gene expression based screening
platform to help understand how our
models reflect the disease so I'll begin
with an outline so first I want to tell
you some of the science behind our work
creating and characterizing new mouse
models for Alzheimer's disease
I want to discuss how we're using a new
catalog of transcriptomic alterations
observed in clinical cohorts to
understand late onset Alzheimer's
disease or load now I'm going to tell
you how this work is helped with a new
encounter Mouse ad panel now that we've
designed with Nanna string and then
finally I'll finish with how we're using
that panel to understand our mouse
models
all this work begins at the NIH
Alzheimer's disease summit a few years
ago the NIH holds a summit every couple
years to bring the field together and
discuss new directions and new
requirements to really tackle
Alzheimer's disease and sort out some
treatments and potential cures in 2015
it was noted that we need a new
generation of in vivo models based upon
human data to explore alzheimer's
disease and related dementias and that's
primarily due to the advances in
genetics genomics and other sa
technologies as well as imaging now
being piloted in clinical studies that
leads us to the next generation of in
vivo models and I'll be talking about
our mouse models we also need to
establish standardized and rigorous
processes for developing and
characterizing these models this is
where some of these gene expression
assays really come in handy there allow
us to standardize standardize our
analysis across all strains and come up
with processes for analysis of those
strains we're also ensuring maximal and
rapid availability to all researchers
for clinical drug development as that's
what our aim really is really strains to
provide preclinical tools that will
require that we align the
pathophysiology of these animal models
so that we can correspond them back to
translatable biomarkers that are
clinically relevant and finally we're
establishing rigorous preclinical
testing guidelines in those animal
models reporting both positive and
negative findings all these requirements
that we're following ended up in the
muddle ad consortium which was funded
following this summit and that's the
model organism development and
evaluation for late onset Alzheimer's
disease it's a consortium that is
embedded within a series of consortia
funded to help tackle Alzheimer s
disease our mission is to expand animal
research models for basic research and
preclinical testing of Canada
therapeutics and we're aiming for 50 new
mouse models of Alzheimer's disease and
Alzheimer's related pathology over five
years
our mission is really built around the
idea that existing mouse models have
been based upon early onset rare genetic
variation that drives fewer than 5% of
Alzheimer's cases observed worldwide and
so there are transgenic models based
upon these rare genetic variants and
these models tend to produce a lot of
amyloid in the brain of the mouse
therefore excellent tools are studying
amyloid deposit however they don't show
the full spectrum of late onset related
phenomenon you see in the majority of
individuals over 95% the public to get
Alzheimer's disease technique its late
onset or sporadic Alzheimer's disease so
we would like to use the genetics in
particular that we've learned about
eight late onset Alzheimer's disease now
in the GOS area to create new mouse
models that current reflect the spectrum
of pathology and Alzheimer's dementia
and so our first goal is to create these
new models of late onset and we're using
CRISPR technologies primarily to do that
we then do a high capacity screening of
all the models including the gene
expression panel I'll be talking about
today as well as deep phenotyping of the
models that look most promising after we
do the screen that deep phenotyping
involves imaging as well as other ohmic
analyses once we have these data we
align the mouse data back to the human
data and I'll show some examples of this
as well where we want to understand what
neuropathology what omics signal systems
biology signals are imaging signals that
we're seeing any given mouse the matches
human phenotype we then move the most
promising models that we can match to a
potential therapeutic the preclinical
testing and we've been piloting that as
well and finally all of the models as
well as well as the data are broadly
distributed with no restrictions on
access and so that's public private
whatever the models are out there so
that people can can pursue their own
basic or preclinical research in
Alzheimer's disease this consortium is
organized across a number of
institutions Indiana University the
Jackson Laboratory stage bio networks
and the University of California Irvine
and within that consortium we have a
number of components so there's a large
bioinformatics NIDA man
core with members from all institutions
a disease modeling project it's being
carried out at the experimental sites
Jackson Lab Indiana University in Irvine
and finally preclinical testing which is
being done at Indiana University of the
Jackson Lab informations being organized
st. bio networks and we also have a new
partner in Pittsburgh our first step of
course is create these models and we're
doing this using CRISPR cast nine gene
editing technology for the most part in
the mouse models this is a still a
fairly new technology but one that has
been proven to be extremely effective in
mouse modeling and we have large
capacity to do this of the Jackson
Laboratory where our mission is to
provide mouse models of human disease so
here's an outline of how that works
we basically ingest CRISPR cassadine
guide RNAs and design goats to embryonic
transfer that produces mosaic mice which
we then breed to produce heterozygous
mutants that we can then breed to
produce homozygous mutants of the given
mutation we're interested in we have
already created quite a few of these
models that are now available through
the Jackson Laboratory there's a
humanized EPP there are a few small
differences in Emily beta precursor
sequence between human and mouse so
we've humanized that with the humanized
evaded knockin Mouse we've also
introduced the a PO II allele series e 2
e 3 and E 4 alleles are all in these
mice now so that we can study the most
commonly associated factor in
Alzheimer's disease the f OE gene
we've also introduced a number of trem
to variants so these are relatively rare
but lead to fairly high odds ratios in
the association studies in particular
the r-47 H mutation and trend to a point
mutation that we have introduced into
the mouse now given that we want a
background for this complex disease that
will be sensitized towards pathology our
base strain is a what we call the b6 h80
so that's the standard black 6 c57 black
6 j mouse strain where we've introduced
both the homozygous apoe4 mutation as
well as home as i get run to our 47 H so
that's H 84 humanized a bowi trem -
that's our baseline strained we've
started to add additional
associated variation to that background
so for instance we have a v6 h80 ABC 7
point mutation strain that's been
associated with Alzheimer's disease as
well as an ABC 7 knockout strain as that
point mutation may be a loss of function
so we want to consider the knockout as
well we have a class 2 mutation plg c2
etc those mice are now available coming
the summer we have the next round of
variants including humanized complement
receptor 1 Iowan r.i.p knockout point
mutation chip 21 b point mutation MTHFR
I see a chem 1 knockout and point
mutations in Sorrell 1 and s and X 1
both part of the retro pathway so we are
continuing through great new mouth mice
again we're aiming for 50 in total doing
about 8 to 10 variants per year over the
next 5 years or over the five-year
period we're two years in right now
we're also humanizing the talus so of
course tau pathology is a major
component of Alzheimer's disease and
there are a number of potential splice
variants and ice core bearings in the
human that may or may not be
recapitulated in the mouse house so
we're humanizing that gene so that we
have the faithful human towel in the
mouse so that we can then add additional
mutations which may further drive
pathology yet according to G boss all of
these models are up kept an updated
table at the model 18 org webpage once
we create these models are real question
is how do we align the human pathology
with a given mouse model again it's a
complex disease so at first we don't
expect any of these models to have full
late onset Alzheimer's pathology however
we can pick them apart we can do MRI as
well as PET imaging to match back to the
human imaging studies particularly Abney
we can do neuropathology of course match
that back to the human and finally we
can do a lot of genomics proteomics and
metabolomics so these omics studies that
allow us to do really direct homology
comparison between the human and mouse
as genes are overwhelmingly shared
between the two species to do this we
really need to go to the human data and
allow the human data to tell us what is
in our house and fortunately there's
quite a data universe for Alzheimer's
disease that's just recently expanded
these include things like the Alzheimer
disease so can sequencing project the
Alzheimer's is the disease neuroimaging
initiative and what I'm showing here
which is the accelerating medicine
partnerships for Alzheimer's disease
here is the amp ad knowledge portal
which is hosted by sage bionetworks and
available at this URL here you can
access content across multiple studies
multiple data types in particular we're
interested in the human genomics of late
onset Alzheimer's disease right now and
there have been three major studies that
are all in being a baby datasets there's
a cohort from the religious order study
a member aging project at Rush
University
Ross map of 700 individuals with dorsal
lateral prefrontal cortex samples Mount
Sinai brain Bank 300 samples from a
number of brain regions and Myo clinic
joining 70 samples from cerebellum and
temporal cortex of course these are all
post-mortem samples in cohorts that are
enriched generally balanced for
Alzheimer's disease mild cognitive
impairment as well as some some non
effective controls so this really gives
us a broad assessment of how Alzheimer's
disease at least at the endpoint has
affected multiple brain regions in three
different different populations from
around the United States now all of
these studies have been published and
I'm showing the references here this was
a series of papers of a period in
scientific data these are all the
individual study cohorts analyzed
individually and presented along with
the additional information for instance
any proteomics and/or clinical data they
have for these cohorts from those
studies however what has also been done
is a meta-analysis across all of those
studies and this allows us to basically
harmonize across those studies bring all
the data together and provide a common
baseline and a common catalog of
potential variation in gene expression
due to Alzheimer's disease
okay so this begins with the multi
method co-expression network analysis
where all of the data reprocessed
in a harmonized way and that includes
some sample swaps across the different
groups so that all of the sequencing
technologies can be aligned we then take
all those data and use a variety of
network analyses so commonly used
techniques such as WGC na
along with some newer techniques like
Eugenia and Trina all are operating on
all of these data allowing us to find
clusters of co-expressed genes that can
be related to Alzheimer's disease each
of those comes up with clusters and from
those we find consensus modules
consensus clusters that are reproducible
across all of those different techniques
in all of these different studies we
then ask if any of those modules are
immature genes that are differentially
expressed in cases versus controls right
because we really want the modules that
are related to Alzheimer's disease
pathology and we found a number of those
and that gives us a set of Alzheimer's
associated co-expression gene modules
from human cohorts and I want to show
you what we found we found in fact 32
expression modules that are related to
late onset Alzheimer's disease and I'm
showing them here and this is a matrix
view of the overlaps in gene content
between these modules okay so what the
first thing you see is of course there
are a few very strongly overlapping
groups of Bonneville's and this is
because we tend to see similar pathology
in the different studies and/or the
different brain regions it's finding the
consistency in outputs across all of
these studies and as we start to look
into what these blocks are we can do
analyses such as cell type specificity
so we ask if the genes within these
modules are enriched in certain cell
types signatures mostly that have been
derived from recent a single-cell RNA
seek analysis and you can see that sure
enough they are the first month module
blocks are strongly enriched and
astrocyte individual and microglial
cells are microglial genes and so this
is suggesting a strong inflammation
component the next block is strongly
enriched in neuron related genes and
that next block pin is if strongly
enriched in myelin island Union only
oligodendrocyte
and so we can start to apply some
functional annotations to be it's noting
that the first blacks astrocytes the
next is really the inflammatory
component a combination of astrocytes
endothelial microglial genes we have a
larger neuron suggesting or a
degeneration we have large
oligodendrocyte and glial genes
suggesting things like adjustments in
myelination perhaps dko myelination and
then finally there's a set of mixed
modules that have to do with things like
stress response and strong response to
unfolded proteins that are relevant to
Alzheimer's disease and us as we
understand some of the pathology for
instance with amyloid and so these tend
to be more more unique in different
brain regions it's what we found perhaps
across different studies as well okay so
this is our baseline understanding the
cell types we can of course also note
that many of those stress response are
not cell type-specific so these may be
throughout many cells within the brain
next we looked at known pathways for
Alzheimer's disease
see if basically if there's an overlap
between these modules and these module
blocks and known associations for
instance genes and DB gap genes that
have shown up in the eye gap a very
large uaaaah study Cheng pathways
related to Alzheimer's disease
Ohman annotations etc and what we find
is that the three major blocks
astrocytes inflammation in neuron are
all strongly enriched in this known
information whereas when we look at the
oligodendrocyte as well as those stress
response modules they're not represented
in the published gene sets in the
annotated gene sets so that might be
some new information that we're getting
from these modules in particular that as
a course is joined by this known
information giving us a more complete
catalog of Alzheimer s pathology finally
we can look for sex specific signatures
these populations are fairly balanced in
terms of males and females and maybe a
little surprisingly maybe not we're
seeing very strong enrichment across
these different modules in these
different module blocks across different
studies in male versus female effects so
for instance we see the inflammation in
both males and females but it's it's
stronger in females
microglial activation for instance
whereas we're seeing stronger blossom
neurons at least in the gene expression
level in females than males okay so this
also sets up some interesting questions
when we think about modeling we're at
course modeling both sexes in our mouse
studies and so we can also look to align
this back and understand how our mouse
models may reflect or not reflect in
some cases these sex specific
differences the one sees in clinical
studies okay so this this set up a
question for us how do we take a mouse
model and effectively screen its gene
expression patterns relative to all of
these very diverse and very interesting
Alzheimer's related modules in humans
ultimately we can do RNA seek but on a
sample by sample basis doing it and say
a high food high capacity screen we
wanted a somewhat quicker option where
we could really get at this information
in a more effective way and and that's
when we turned in the Nano string group
and helped them develop the encounter
Mouse ad panel so what this is is a
panel of seven or 70 Mouse gene probes
with an option at up to 30 additional
custom genes in a given study that
allows us to cover these thirty and baby
modules and we really tried to maximize
coverage across all of the modules we've
also included things like the top
amputee candidates so there have been
quite a bit of work in prioritizing
candidates in the accelerating medicines
partnership we've made sure to include
all of their genes such as their top 30
as well as their Agoura targets or or as
a platform they have to agglomerate
information around new gene expression
signatures and really prioritize targets
and then given that we ranked all of the
genes by representation in the modules
and not only just representation in
terms of say a centralized principal
component or centroid for a given module
but also we go deeper and look across
module principal components and make
sure that we're getting maybe some
secondary signals in those modules which
in fact are very large some of them are
thousands of genes okay so that allows
us to score every gene is tau central it
is for a number of dimensions within
each module
we then wanted to make sure that there
was expression the mouse right this is a
mouth panel so we want to see genes that
are expressed in the mouse brain so we
validated an orthogonal expression in
the mouse at six months of age and
finally we added ten housekeeping genes
which are very useful for normalizing
across the the Nano string platform and
multiple samples and so after doing this
we our coverage ranges from about 76 to
278 genes in each module no but again
the modules overlap strongly so of
course many of these genes that we
select and put on this panel are
representing many modules okay so how
does this panel work well so what nana
strings molecular barcodes do is provide
digital detection technology capable of
highly multiplexed analysis about 2 800
RNAs they also have DNA and protein
targets as well here we're looking at
RNAs and like I said we we selected 770
key genes with the option of 30 custom
probes per experiment what happens is a
couple probes hybridize directly to a
target molecule in solution so this all
happens in solution there is no
amplification required after
hybridization the samples are
transferred to the end counter
instrument and that removes excess
probes then binds the purified target
probe complexes and immobilizes an
alliance to an imaging surface so that
we can quantify the amount or output
they're then scanned by automated
fluorescent micro microscopy barcodes
are counted for each target molecule and
data are exported and I'll show you how
simple that file format is and so
overall this platform provides a
relatively simple precise qualitative
analysis for nucleic acids in this case
messenger RNAs okay back to the genes
here's an example of some of those gene
rankings I talked about and how we
prioritize the genes so here I'm showing
prioritized candidates actually within
one of those modules a temporal cortex
green module from from one of the
cohorts we found the genes within that
module again there are many so we asked
which ones first of all I'm a mouse homo
long so there's a human mouse gene
signal in both cases we looked at those
again that are Express
in the mouse brain all these are
expressed very well with TPMS at least
four in this group we also computed the
module gene rank score so this is
looking across the principal components
of the module how important in health
central is that gene that's what the
ranking is based on in this list of
course taking the absolute value so that
so that we can see both up and down
regulated genes relative to the the
module principal components and then
finally we made sure an annotated if for
instance a gene like PA k1 was a drug
discovery target that's been prioritized
by a baby so we did this for all genes
and that's where we are ranked to cover
most modules and our coverage looks like
this so as we look across the modules
across the entire 30 you can see that in
many of these cases there are thousands
of genes and the modules and that's why
we're in a log scale here because the
the module memberships actually go up to
almost 5,000 for some of these modules
the smallest ones are about 500 so this
is a pretty broad catalog again of
Alzheimer's disease and we wanted to
cover these modules evenly and cover
each of them well and so again you can
see that we range from about 78 to over
200 genes per module there's at least 5%
coverage in every module and so and
we've also again picked the most central
genes to the various dimensions within
each module okay so this allows us a
pretty comprehensive overview of what
pathologies related Alzheimer's disease
at least at the RNA level that a mouse
might be showing hey given this we
wanted to try it out on some of our
models of course and so I want to show
you some results from an example now
study so these are this is our first
round of models so and I'm showing these
because these are the modules we've had
our models we've had time to both create
an age to 14 months and assay so this is
a a data set of 144 samples from our
model 80 mice and here we have four
strains so we have this black six
control again that's a 57 black 6j the
standard laboratory Mouse that's our
baseline Mouse that we're going to model
on top of in model ad we've taken that
we've added the apoe4 allele
that's a knock in different places the
mouse apoE with human a polly and
particularly the e4 allele we then took
another strain which is the r-47 age
point mutation which we've CRISPR it
into the mouse because there's good
homology in the tribe to gene between
human and mouse we're able to CRISPR in
the our 40s mhm point mutation and then
finally that b6h 80 model the baseline
of our all of our fourth forthcoming
mouse models which is the a belief or in
turn to our 47 h double mutant that's
our sensitizer for what is it come we
looked at three different ages for 18
and 14 months so that's basically one
one age that's coming right at a
development at the four-month sort of
middle age NOS at eight month
an early older age Mouse I would say 14
months we're also further aging these
mice out to 24 months to get a really
elderly Mouse we don't have those data
yet because we're still aging cohorts
but this gives us at least a start at
some of the aging processes that we can
assess in these mice of course we looked
at both males and females we're doing
that for all of our models within model
ad and we looked at six replicas for
each of these cohorts and that's how we
get 244 samples okay so that's our
standard for doing genomics is six
replicates so that's what we're using
for the before the encounter Mouse ad
panel each sample was normalized in the
geometric commune of the 10 house giving
genes and then we've log transformed all
values for the standard way the people
tend to analyze the now string data
which matches very closely to what one
does with RNA seek data now I do want to
note that these are still fairly young
mice and these are not many lien drivers
about of Alzheimer's disease which means
that these mice actually don't have a
lot of Alzheimer's disease pathology in
the brains yet again it was only 14
months that's you know maybe a 50 year
old human so we're continuing a G's mice
further to see if they do develop
pathology however we know that in humans
just having a pony for in trend to our
47 H probably isn't enough to drive all
ours disease alone there are probably
other genetic factors other contributing
factors that need to be there and so at
14
for instance these mice do not have
amyloid or tau pathology they're still
aging perhaps still developing it so
that's worth keeping in mind as we look
through some of the omics data and ask
whether we're hitting the right pathways
with these models here's what the data
looked like from Nenana string
technology and as I mentioned it's
exported basically as a flat file you
can load it up into Excel
see all your samples see all the
technical information meta information
get useful metrics like the binding
density for instance telling you how
well the sample worked in the encounter
machine it gives you your housekeeping
genes and then a number of genes that
you've selected to put onto the panel
and I'm showing the first few here and
you can see that we have very clear
quantification across all of these
samples of all of these genes that's an
easy data set to work work with these
come in by the way batches of 12 so we
did all of these in in runs of 12
samples each and we get a number of
series of flat files like this which are
easily imported and analyzed how do we
analyze it so we thought about a couple
of ways to do this the first analysis
was to model just by Factor ok so we
have a number of variables here in our
data set we have sex we have age then we
have a couple of genetic mutations and
we've also have a double mutant so we
mix those in some cases
okay so first to ask what are the
effects of all of these factors we just
the log of expression estimated by the
encounter technology and ran a
regression model to assess the effects
independent effects from each of these
factors x age apoe4 allele turn through
our queries i've initially if we do that
we can see differential expression by
factor pretty clearly so for instance we
have sex related genes so I believe this
is males relative to females we have a
number of genes both up and down
regulated in the left hand okay no 549
total age related genes we see stronger
effects and more significant effects
across 338 genes for the apoe4 knockin
we see fewer genes affected 77 mostly
upregulated but some down regulated and
finally for the trend to or for u7h
mutation we see 133 significantly
differentially expressed genes both up
and down and again this is out of 800
probes 800 genes they were on this assay
so we are seeing some effects
surprisingly we see strong sex and age
effects so that has to be flipped into
our analysis as well we've been wanted
to align from the human data or sorry
from the malleus data back to the human
data and for this I mean we did a number
of methods we did the first thing that
most people do is just to look and see
if there's an overlap between
differential expression in our dataset
and the human dataset and sure enough we
see a lot of overlap for instance doing
a Fisher's exact test for 4 account
overlaps we see a lot of significance we
can do things like Jaccard similarity
across the gene sets that also gives us
some strong significant results and and
that's that's good but we really want to
move forward and ask well if we see that
overlap are we seeing the same effects
are we seeing genes upregulated in
alzheimer's disease also up in the mouse
or are we seeing opposite effects in the
mouse are we not seeing coherent effects
within a given module ok so to assess
this we developed correlation scores we
were basically just looking at Pearson
correlations of the effects in cases
versus control in humans versus the
effects of a given Mouse factor okay so
here I'm showing a couple of results
where we plot on the x axis the log fold
change in alzheimer's versus non
alzheimer's controls in human genes and
human module versus a given Mouse factor
from the linear module so that could be
sex it could be age it could be a belief
or a trend - and we just compute the
correlation between the human gene
expression log fold change and the mouse
gene expression effect and so here are
two examples one is an uncorrelated
module so the phd turquoise module shown
here on the left we selected the genes
in that module that represented as
probes on the mouse ad panel and plotted
them all against one another in scatter
plot here comparing the human expression
versus the effect from the apoe4 allele
and you can see that there's no
correlation that it's significant the
correlation is point zero eight four
with these numbers that's not remotely
what we would call significant and so we
call that an uncorrelated module for
that factor equal before and that amount
a human module page t-shirt turquoise on
the other hand when we look at the trend
to our for a 7h effect and compare it to
a different module SDG turquoise and we
see a strong correlation and a very
significant correlation between those
two okay so this is suggesting that that
module which I believe this inflammatory
module is is recapitulated to some
degree by the trend to our for u7h Mouse
mutation so we did this for all factors
across all modules and the results look
something like this it's all walking
through this first across the top we
have all of the different human modeling
or MPD modules and they've been grouped
in these consensus clusters so like I
showed in the overlap there were these
large blocks of modules with similar
gene content here they're in what we
call consensus clusters and we can go
through and annotate those consensus
clusters as we've done here by certain
biological annotations and/or cell types
so for instance I defined closure
there's consensus cluster media cytokine
signaling and big immune response that's
really microglial consensus see is
synaptic signaling nervous system
development which you know given the way
the gene ontology annotations work that
really means we're looking at neuron
genes here in this context in fences
cluster PV is myelination neuron and
glial development and astrocytes so that
more mixed module but oligodendrocyte
signals as well and then finally the the
consensus cluster here which has sort of
the stress response that shows of cell
cycle DNA repair and RNA metabolism gene
ontology annotations so we have those
blocks of modules that are all quite
similar across human and then down the
left or looking at three different Mouse
ages and looking at the different
factors so the age has such a strong
effect we found that it made more sense
to present results separated by age so
now we look stratified by age we look at
effects from be before knockin the
effects of male versus female sex I
believe this is male coded as one so
these are male differences from a female
baseline
and finally the trunk to our four u7h
point mutation and then we
systematically computed these
correlation scores and saw that we have
either positive correlations in blue or
negative correlations in red across all
of these different modules Hey and so
when you step back I think the first
interesting thing to note is that we
tend to be overlapping more with these
baby modules which I remind you are
postmortem samples from ancient
individuals in the older mice in the 14
month-old mouse we tend to get more
overlap stronger association stronger
correlations most of those are negative
and and that again goes back to the idea
that these mice actually don't have the
pathological load that we saw in the
human samples and so maybe in some cases
we're not seeing the response for
instance an immune response that one
sees due to Emma Lloyd in the brain and
the humans is not showing up as well
here and in fact we're seeing an anti
correlation with trem to our four u7h
and the immune response sucks consensus
cluster B and and that suggests to us
that we're seeing their eye pathway
there we're getting the right process
but because there is no pathology in
these mouse brains we're actually seeing
and go in a different direction so it'll
be very interesting to see as we develop
mice or aged mice that develop these
pathologies such as Emily tell what the
effect of this bearing will be I think
we've already hit the right pathway well
then see if we're hitting the right
direction in some cases here we're
already hitting the right direction for
instance and consensus cluster sees or
the neuron health series of modules are
apoe4 module a point for mutation that
not in already matches pretty well what
we're seeing there between the mouse and
human and so that that's powerful
information because now we know that if
we really want to study the most
Alzheimer's relevant instances of the
pathology represented by consensus
cluster see that apoe4 Mouse is already
a useful Mouse to carry forward and and
study that the other thing I'll note is
that we sometimes see some changes in
the correlations with age as well and
and that shows up in a belief for Mouse
on this far right consensus cluster II
where early you see a correlation with
with some of the old timers related
pathology but that goes negative as you
go later and
could be a an issue of insufficient
aging and their mythology in the mouse
or it could be that the apoe4 genetic
factor actually it is not contributing
and is not correlated with those modules
later in life so will will find and find
out more as we age these mice and add
additional pathology driving mutations
we can also catalog strains versus these
different modules and so this is the
same set of modules again grouped in the
same way but instead of pulling out the
linear model effects did I show it from
the mice earlier we just assess every
single Mouse strain again we have six
replicates so we can actually do this
with fairly high confidence look at what
is an AoE for male with like an equally
four trend to double mutant male versus
female trim to male and the idea here is
if you really want to do a preclinical
follow-up or a detailed experimental
follow-up this is a way that you can
select that Mouse that's going to best
match the pathology that you're most
interested in okay and so you can see
that again we see pretty similar
correlations and strength of
correlations in both positive and
negative directions for each of these
mice with each of these modules but
there's some additional information here
for instance that can since this cluster
sieve and has correlation with the apoe4
that actually a correlation is really in
the male mice and not so much in the
female mice at least not at a
significant level okay so one might want
to study both males and females if
you're staying that pathway with apoe4
Mouse and see if that any effects that
you're following up on are going to
match these sex specific effects that
we're seeing in the mouse it also tells
you that for instance if you want to
think about these stress response
outcomes and consensus cluster 3 the
trem two females are really where you
want to look either at middle or later
ages and so by by doing this analysis
and this is again all with the no string
Mouse ad platform we can get a quick
idea of what these mouse models are
showing relative to the human modules
we've also done RNA seek on these same
mice sort of the proof of concept in a
pilot we want to do RNA seek as well and
we
the same analysis went through all the
different strains compared to all these
different mouse mods are human waddles
from Aunt baby of course here we can do
it was a full repertoire of all the
genes in these modules and so the
results look very similar when you look
across the board one notable thing of
course is that the correlations get
weaker when you look across all of the
genes right because many of these genes
are more peripheral to the modules and
maybe are not showing as robust in
effect and so that's it perhaps
initiating some noise into the
correlation analysis which weakens the
correlations at the same time the number
of genes is higher so the significance
stays there and so that's interesting to
note that with the mouse ad panel from
another string we actually see twice the
level of correlation basically after
we've selected out the most relevant
genes but otherwise we see very similar
effects across all of the strains and
all the various human clusters and we
summarized this with a plot showing how
well each of these correlation scores
match between human and mouse in RNA
sync versus nano string so basically
we're gonna I'm going to show you a
scatter plot of these outcomes here
these correlation scores across the grid
and they look like this okay so this is
back to the factor analysis where I'm
not going strain my strain I got to do a
little busy so here I'm just showing the
different factors age 84 sex and trim 2
or 4 u7h factors looking across modules
module that is MPD module to Mouse
factor correlation scores in RNA seek on
the x axis and the same thing for the
mouse a/b panel on the y axis and so you
can see that there's a very strong
correlation there definitely a
significant correlation suggesting that
you know for the purposes that we've set
out here which is to compare the mouse
signals with the human signals we're
basically getting the same result when
we compare using RNAi C or the Mouse AV
panel again I also noted earlier that
you tend to get the stronger
correlations with a 80 panel because
we've narrowed down to the strongest
most central genes of each of those
modules and so the y axis has a broader
scale than the x axis interestingly this
also improves with
age you can see some of the strongest
correlations are that age factor and if
we stratify by age and look at all these
this relationship again we see that as
the mice age and hopefully and it
appears that is the case that the mouse
signals become more relevant to the
human signals in the F ADHD cohorts that
we're getting not only a better match in
both cases with the human data but we're
also getting better agreement with the
different experimental platforms RNA so
you can laugh a bit now ok so we think
we have a very good panel to move
forward with as we create an age more
mice within model ad and we'll be doing
this all along and sharing that data as
we do it so all of our data are
available through that same ant baby
portal that I showed earlier we
collaborate closely with the ant baby
consortium and we're in fact using their
same data dissemination platform which
is MPT portal org
here is the example showing some of our
contributions on their web page but you
can go there you can link today that we
just posted new data from some mouse
models on here and we'll do that
continuously over the years we also link
to these data on our own site model - 80
org the panel is available as well so
the encounter Mouse ad panel is
available today from downstream we're
using it you can - and there's a human
version coming as well so if you have a
human cohort so you'd like to screen in
the same way that panel will arrive
again at 7 or some of these genes
they're specific for Alzheimer's disease
studies assess from 3080 associated gene
expression modules as I've described
that represent in here we're naming 23
different third-generation pathway
processes and so that allows again
reproducible monitoring of all the
numbers progression with age in the
model and functional screening of
potential therapeutics because of course
you can use this as a validation
technique if you see variation within a
given module do you think is a drug
target then you can of course do nano
string analysis and your preclinical
studies as well and see if the drug is
mediating that that targeted pathway and
we're doing some of that of course in
our preclinical testing core in milady
this
of course compatible with any mouse
model and customizable again with the 30
additional user-defined genes and so
we've been doing that because many of
these models have say a humanized gene
or genes with a number of snips in them
where we want to be able to quantify
that targeted genetic mutation and at
high precision as well and that requires
moving away from the standard Mouse
sequence okay so this is available from
no string and that's where I wanted to
wrap up by thanking all of us in the
model ad consortium that involves a
number of people from Indiana University
the Jackson Laboratory universe
california-irvine sage bionetworks and
Nam University of Pittsburgh I also
thank our collaborators at nano spring
well this developed this mouse ad panel
and have helped guide our use of it and
finally our funding source is through
the National Institute of Aging a couple
of you 54s to find my lady and I'll
finish by noting we have a number of
contacts we have male dog web page we
have an email address model ad at IUPUI
edu and we're also on Twitter and model
ad Paul's Nanna string of course can be
reached at their own webpage and info
and then the string com
thank you very much thank you dr. Carter
for that informative presentation I'd
also like to thank nano string for
making today's educational webcast
possible before we go I want to remind
everyone that this webcast will be
available for on-demand viewing through
June 2019 as a final reminder dr. Carter
will follow up with any questions you've
submitted via email that's all for now
and thanks for joining us and we'll see
you next time bye bye